so there is a scam that's been going
around for about six months or so that
these crooks used my picture and Mark
Cuban's picture and the the
quote-unquote company the scam is called
financial health reset and they put out
a series of emails and other things out
through the internet that Dave Ramsey
and Mark Cuban were predicting the end
of the American economy and in order to
be prepared for this disaster you needed
to buy their crap and it's a complete
scam Cuban has come out and said the
same thing and you know I've talked
about it a couple of times but I we keep
getting inquiries here and we've turned
it over to the FBI and we you know put
out cease and desist orders on it
because they're not gonna they're gonna
ignore that because it crooks they knew
they were lying when they launched the
thing it's a complete you know they feed
on people that scams you know let me
tell you an interesting thing I read a
book years ago by a guy that was in jail
because he was a con artist and the book
was called and I read that book probably
thirty years ago con man or saint and I
don't even remember the story of his con
but he had a con that he ran and he was
in jail he he talks about the con in the
book and he talks about how he made
people money - in the book of course and
that's why the whole con manner st.
thing but he was a con man but the only
thing I do remember about the book was
and it stuck with me that it is very
difficult for you and me to be conned
unless we're one of two things
greedy or afraid fear will set you up to
be conned the economy is collapsing Dave
Ramsey and Mark Cuban say and by our
stupid stuff here so you'll be ready
when the economy collapses that's a
fear-based con and of course you know
easy money something for nothing is
greed
and that will set you up for a con but
if you can avoid fear and greed as
emotions as an emotional reaction to an
offer you can avoid a con because cons
are always feeding on one of those two
things the fear-based cons usually will
feed on the elderly and they'll feed on
the illiterate people who are who aren't
well educated or smart one of the two
and they feed on that you're most likely
to get the fear-based con or fall for it
in those cases and you know I'm this one
the main thing we're seeing is elderly
people contacting us coins they've
really Purdue they ribs you've really
predicted me in the world no Dave's
never predicted in the world as a matter
of fact I have made an actual commitment
that even if I think the world is going
to end I'm not gonna predict it because
the financial people are the world's
worst at predicting the end of the world
and they just sometimes I get old they
get they lose their hope or whatever and
they predicted in the world I'm not
going to predict in the world I'm not
gonna write a book predicting in the
world and I know other financial people
that have done that and they really
believed the world was coming to an end
and that's certainly their right to do
that or whatever but I don't think the
world's coming to an end and I really
don't and I really don't think our
economy is about to collapse and I don't
think that Trump is going to collapse
our economy and if Hillary had been
elected I don't think she's gonna
collapse our economy I just don't think
they're that strong for one thing
they're they're not nearly anyone I'm
nearly as big a deal as they thought
they were and so you know our it's just
more to it than that so if you get an
email with me predicting the end of the
world you can know it's a scam and for
today if you get one from financial
health reset a hundred percent you know
it's a scam and it's got me or Mark
Cuban on it either one and that's the
one that's been going around so just let
you guys know if you hear that somewhere
somebody posts it on Facebook or
something you can just immediately
respond and go heard Dave Ramsey talking
about it complete scam hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
now